bonjour je me présente José Cachin mare
adjoint délégué à la culture et à
l'événemen cel à montinil Bretonneux et
si je suis présent devant vous cher
public c'est simplement pour vous donner
l'envie et vous donner surtout trois
bonnes raisons d'aller assister au
spectacle Le Cabaret des frissons
[Musique]
garanti la première raison c'est tout
simplement l'occasion comme je le disais
d'assister à un spectacle qui s'est mêlé
à la fois théâtre magie et chanson et
tout cela en parlant de mangeaille le
fromage et les boîes la confiture et les
cornons
laard la mayonnaise et les
cornichons la seconde raison c'est que
si vous avez la chance de faire partie
du public vous aurez peut-être une
seconde chance c'est celle tout
simplement de vous faire inviter sur
scène pour danser un slow et enfin la
dernière raison c'est que le théâtre de
cristal est une troupe inclusive qui
associe
indistinctement des comédiens et des
comédiennes en situation de handicap
pour faire ce tour j'ai besoin d'une
bonne table un verre une bouteille et de
tubes je vais faire passer le verre à la
place de la bouteille et la bouteille à
la place du
verre et voilà le travail si vous voulez
qu'on boit un coup ensemble il faut de
ver
et de
bouteilles à la petite soif à la grande
soif alors si ces trois raisons vous ont
convaincu vous êtes invité à venir
assister au Cabaret des frissons
garantis qui se déroulera le mardi 6
février à 20h30 à la salle jacqubrelle
de montinil
bretonne